en eso michael kelly y álvaro vargas y a
qué atribuyes sus detenciones
buenas noches gracias santiago por esta
oportunidad de compartir con la
audiencia de france veinte y cuatro para
nosotros es muy importante denunciar lo
que está pasando en nicaragua y este
michael hill y álvaro vargas se suma a
esa lista de 37 presos políticos de alto
nivel que se agregan también a 150
presos políticos que están vinculados a
nivel territorial a tener posiciones de
oposición valga la redundancia el
régimen de ortega estos dos personajes
como bien es ha señalado son el
presidente y el vicepresidente del
consejo superior de la empresa privada
es decir el grupo empresarial que
aglutina el consejo que aglutina al
sector empresarial de todo el país
recientemente electos en su quehacer
está orientado a fortalecer el sector el
sector privado a desarrollar procesos de
formación acompañamiento para que haya
mejoras tecnológicas y desarrollo
empresarial y de ninguna manera podemos
admitir que estén vinculados
dinero ni a nada de lo que el régimen
les atribuye pues estos cargos son los
mismos que han señalado a otros 37
opositores
ahora hay qué consecuencias podrían
tener estas detenciones para lo que es
la economía de nicaragua teniendo en
cuenta que como usted bien decía
hablamos de líderes empresariales muy
importantes del país
bueno hay que señalar que de los 37
opositores anteriormente encarcelados
también está el ex presidente del cosep
josé adán aguerrí que en días pasados
más de 500 empresas de toda la región
centroamericana se han sumado a la
demanda de su libertad el
encarcelamiento de estos dos nuevos
funcionarios del cosep pues lo que hacen
es relevar la denuncia de las
violaciones y las arbitrariedades que se
están cometiendo en nicaragua y como
este régimen manipula la justicia para
judicializar perseguir ya acallar las
voces que son opositoras a su régimen
pero además pone en evidencia lo que el
día de ayer se discutía en la
organización de estados américanos que
estamos en presencia de un régimen
dictatorial un régimen que ha
prácticamente eliminado todas las
garantías constitucionales a los
nicaragüenses que en este país pues se
vive a un estado de sitio de facto habla
usted de la oea vinculado a eso hay
manera de garantizar que las elecciones
presidenciales de noviembre se lleven a
cabo con normalidad o ya no y que podría
ser la comunidad internacional y
organismos como la oea
definitivamente lo que sucedió ayer fue
el antesala del desconocimiento al
proceso electoral puesto que ortega no
ha asumido ninguna de las
recomendaciones en materia de reforma
electoral ni tampoco en condiciones de
garantías constitucionales y
políticas para el pueblo de nicaragua el
régimen prácticamente como dije
anteriormente y lo ha señalado la unión
europea en su última resolución se vive
un estado de sitio de facto en el que
todas las libertades la libertades y
garantías constitucionales han sido
suspendidas en el país y nicaragua no
hay derecho a organización no hay
derecho a la protesta no hay derecho a
la movilización y siete precandidatos a
la presidencia están detenidos dentro
dentro de esos 37 personas de alto nivel
de la oposición que hemos señalado
anteriormente